no more half truths
tell me everything or i'm ending the
journey now i mean it harry if i do i
risk destroying the second foundation
before it's even been created hey guys
pete here today i'm going to do another
book to show changes video for
foundation covering episodes seven and
eight and i mentioned in my last one of
these that it's getting harder to do it
and that's continued to be the case
there's only a few things to mention
here so i'll try to keep it short and
then come back and do something more
comprehensive at the end of the season
where we have a better idea of where
things are heading i'm gonna talk about
things that happened in the books so
there will be some light spoilers in
that way but i'm gonna try to do it so
that i don't give away future plot
points and with that out of the way
let's get into it
the first change to talk about is the
reveal of the second foundation harry
did keep the details to himself other
than saying that it was an essential
part of his plan but in the original
trilogy you don't learn about this until
the second half of the second book and
then the third book is actually called
the second foundation and you find out a
whole lot more about it revealing that
it exists earlier is probably not a bad
idea because it does sort of come out of
nowhere and it feels somewhat like an
afterthought if not a deus ex machina
when you do learn about it in episode 8
we find out the reason that harry's
going to helicon is to set this up at
what he calls stars in the idea of star
zen does come from the book but it has
nothing to do with harry's home planet
or this idea of a dark star that keeps
it hidden second foundation is hidden
but it's in a completely different way
when asimov came back and wrote the
prequels at the end of his life he
basically retconned the original trilogy
by adding a backstory for the second
foundation so it seemed like the show
was picking up on that and one of the
other changes they added this idea of
gail saying that she can feel the future
setting her apart as someone who
basically has powers that's something
that does come directly from the book
and is tied to the second foundation but
the powers are different in the books
there are several characters that asimov
calls mentalix they have abilities but
they weren't clairvoyant or precogs they
were telepathic and i won't explain that
all now because maybe we'll know a
little bit more by the end of the season
considering that salvor has some things
going on too but what seems most
interesting about this to me is that you
make this big change where you keep
harry's consciousness alive in the books
the character came back at different
points in the story but never in an
active role it was basically just to
reinforce the idea that he saw these
crises that the foundation would
experience ahead of time and he would
reveal that through pre-recorded
messages which was reassuring to people
and helped to keep the plan going i
think keeping his consciousness involved
could be a good thing it keeps jared
harris involved and you could bring in
some of the things from the prequels and
have them happen concurrently with the
first foundation's development the
second foundation doesn't come into play
until something like 300 years after the
exile determinus but the whole thing
with gail leaving makes that character
the big mystery here
david goyer has said that gail is a
combination of two characters and as her
story unfolds it's hard to say who the
second one is i thought she had aspects
of hugo's story he was harry's right
hand man who came up with the idea of
the second foundation the trip she's on
now to synax would put her there around
the time the first book ends but in the
show's present the terminus timeline
can't catch up to that by the end of the
first season so she'll be asleep for the
major developments that happen on
terminus in the early years of the first
foundation it's possible that she could
go to synax and then still come back to
form the second foundation but it
doesn't really feel likely after she
left i mean she does have rach's knife
which may still contain a copy of harry
but who even knows how that works so at
this point the idea of her being a
combination of gail and hugo amarill is
less compelling than it was she could
come back to terminus later and take on
one of the roles there or she could turn
out to be one of the important players
in the second foundation like preem
pulver or she could take on the main
role from the sequels since that
character was special in a way that some
people seem to think doesn't exist in
the foundation series i don't know to me
it's not that worrying that she seems to
be able to see the future because i
imagine that there will be asimov style
mentalix introduced either way i just
wonder what that ability is leading to
because it's kind of exciting to not
know what's in store other than she is
definitely the voice of the narrator
that is speaking to us from the future
and i suppose that's enough about that
the big change that happened this week
that i've seen a lot of chatter about
was that demarzel killed halima which
appears to violate asimov's laws of
robotics and i talked about this in my
ama video but just to reiterate the
showrunner explained the main robot
character that connects all the series
together ardaniel oliva is part of the
irobot's rights so the apple series
can't use that name and some of the
details related to the character it
sounds complicated but they have access
to the demarzel side of the character
which is the same but it doesn't sound
like they can use that name and possibly
not refer directly to some of the things
that happened in the robot series he
followed that up saying asimov's
robotics laws do exist in the universe
of the show but that doesn't necessarily
mean demarzel is presently bound by them
and to explain further would spoil far
too much so the laws of robotics exist
which means that a robot can't kill a
human even when you factor in the xeroth
law where they can because humanity as a
whole is placed ahead of the fate of a
single human it still isn't easy to do
for reasons that i won't get into in
this video i think the main thing to
keep in mind here is the second part of
his quote there where he says i can't
say more because it would be too much of
a spoiler when i look at that he's
saying that something has happened to
demerszel to block the three laws
and it's been a while since i read the
robot short stories but i can think of
at least one example where they did do
that and there might be more from what i
remember most of those stories revolve
around the implications of the laws
sometimes there's unforeseen things that
happen and sometimes there's unintended
consequences and by the end of the robot
series positronic robots like the neil
are exceedingly rare and that tracks
with demerizel being the last of her
kind in the tv series the laws are
important to how she does what she does
in the big picture of things but it
doesn't seem like it would throw
everything off if there was a different
law and pose that superseded the
original ones for a few centuries
hopefully it's a good idea they do it
for a good reason but i think it's kind
of a wait and see situation and demarzel
killed someone at the beginning of the
second episode either way so this isn't
new something's going on with demerizel
the laws of robotics are really
straightforward so i don't think it's a
situation where they don't understand
how they work and i'm willing to wait
and see where they're going with it it's
like a lot of things that i hear people
say i get where people are coming from
when they say it doesn't feel like what
they expected but i think it's too early
to tell if it's actually a bad thing or
not we're coming up on episode nine it's
pretty well established that they're
doing their own thing and i think that's
a good place to leave things let me know
what you think in the comments who's the
other character that's combined into
gail's storyline please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon